[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let the fun begins
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Productions and 10 years ago we teamed
up with our friends and I made a bit to
start a festival of the best of
independent games from every platform
bringing them together with the players
and also some food and drink and music
and a celebration of video games we call
day of the devs and it's been an amazing
party for 10 years but lately there's
been this Global pandemic and plague
keeping us apart but I'm happy to
announce that here in the 10th year
anniversary of day of the dead as we are
live again here at our old venue the
Midway in San Francisco and it's going
to be an amazing party November 5th it's
free it's all ages uh there's going to
be over 70 games and developers you can
come play the games meet the developers
drink and eat and listen to music and
it's an amazing time and we're expanding
from this big open room outdoors and
even partying Up on the Roof just to
keep it safe so make sure it's fun and
safe and a big party for everybody so
please RSVP below and come did I mention
this free thanks sponsors
[Music]
foreign
so I hope to see you here in San
Francisco November 5th but even if
you're not coming we've got an amazing
digital showcase right now that you can
enjoy showing a lot of the great games
that you're going to see at day of the
devs including some big Heavy Hitters
and some World premieres suspect and
relax and enjoy day of the day
to see it through my muscles
[Music]
who doesn't love the Shovel Knight
series well developer Yacht Club games
is mixing it up with another retro riff
this time with Game Boy Color Aesthetics
it's a little bit Link's Awakening it's
a little bit bloodborne feels Nobody
Does it Like Yacht Club and you're about
to see why
what's up my name is Alec Faulkner and
I'm a game designer and director at
Yacht Club games we're an independent
game studio in Los Angeles California
you may know us from the Shovel Knight
series of games or you might not notice
at all in which case hey it's great to
meet you
but today we're not showing off another
Shovel Knight game instead we've got a
brand new game with brand new gameplay
set in a brand new world and it's called
Mina the hollower
[Music]
foreign
inventor thrust into a bizarre world
full of monsters and mystery
[Music]
she'll need both brains and Brawn to
take on the terrifying Horrors that
await in this challenging
action-adventure RPG
you'll notice Mina's attacks are
intentionally slow so learning proper
spacing and timing is crucial to mean
his survival spamming the attack button
won't work here
but to balance things out Mina has a
powerful tool at her disposal her
signature burrowing technique
while burrowing Mina can't be damaged by
most enemies or hazards so you'll be
burrowing often to dodge danger and dig
to safety
by defeating enemies Mina can collect
their bones and if she collects enough
she's able to Bone up on her research
increasing her knowledge of scientific
Fields like attack power or defense
mean of the hollower also features a new
art style that takes inspiration from
the Game Boy Color era of portable
gaming that means our pixels are big our
color palettes are vibrant and our
characters are small and chunky just the
way we like it
[Music]
we're currently deep into development
and don't yet have a release date but
you can witch list the game on Steam and
learn more about it at
yachtclubgames.com
by the way we also live stream our work
on twitch sometimes so if you want give
us a follow and you'll get a behind the
scenes look at our game development
process all the way from start to finish
thanks so much for listening and we hope
you check out Mina the hollower when it
releases bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
this next game might be the most Nordic
game of all time it's from hyper games
in Norway published by raw Fury in
Sweden based on the moomin's IP from
Finland and scored by Seger Ross from
Iceland this is snuffkin Melody of
Moomin Valley Hi my name is ARA and I'm
from the Norwegian in the studio of
hyper games together with our Palace in
rural Fury we are currently working on
the game snuffkin Melody of Lumin Valley
[Music]
all right
the game is a cozy Adventure game about
restoring Harmony and balance to Lumen
Valley
[Music]
foreign
as a player you will explore the valley
meet a lot of the inhabitants there and
help them solve quests and puzzles in
various ways many times using music as
one of your main mechanics
the game is very much a love letter to
the author artist illustrator Toby Anson
who created the movements
[Music]
thank you
and we want to try to capture a little
bit of the magical Nordic atmosphere
that shines through all of her work
[Music]
the music for the game is composed by
UDA till sets and partly in
collaboration with the Icelandic band
singer Ross
[Music]
we want to make something that feels
like something turbulance on herself
could have envisioned
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
this is a special one for I am a bit a
developer or queen crew games got their
starts in the arcade Biz and the real
world escape room scene the Escape
Academy was their very first console and
PC title it came out four months ago has
already become a Runway hit and they
already had their first DLC coming out
which is pretty sweet it's called escape
from anti-escape Island and we have the
World premiere first look and as a
special bonus
we have a bunch of game codes to give
away that are hidden throughout this
broadcast uh maybe some are obvious
maybe some aren't so obvious but if you
freeze frame you might get a free game
out of it enjoy
[Music]
I don't know about this something about
this juice Lounge feels out of place
hello
anybody here what the heck is up with
this place
Escape Academy escape from anti-escape
Island
and now from developer worm Club out of
Melbourne Australia I'm pleased to bring
you the Charming irreverent and epic
conclusion to the Frog detective series
with the appropriately titled frog
Detective 3.
hello I'm Grace brooksma creative
director of Wham club I'm here today to
show you the final chapter of frog
detective corruption at Cowboy County
in collaboration with The Talented
Thomas balka Dr Dan Golding and Olivia
Haynes worm Club has been working hard
to deliver the most advanced and
mind-blowing video game of the decade
you may think I'm joking but you would
be mistaken
[Music]
[Applause]
as you may remember the Lost frog
detective Adventure had you on the edge
of your seat with the shocking notebook
stealing Cliffhanger frog detective 3
picks up right where we left off
detective's arrival to the wild west to
help Lobster cop solve the mystery of
the sheriffless county
but to the detective's shock the case
has already been resolved by the number
one best detective
we should have known Lobster cops
abilities fire outweigh frog Detectives
but despite this Speedy resolution it's
not long before another mystery is afoot
all the hats in cowboy County have gone
missing what the its frog detective's
job to recover the missing hats so
you'll need to use your expert
investigation skills to question
suspects find Clues and solve the
mystery
thank you
[Music]
foreign
also you can ride around on a scooter
[Music]
I'm excited for you to play frog
detective 3 corruption at Cowboy County
with shocking twists and turns never
before seen in the medium of video games
we know this exciting finale will make
you say I understand why this took three
years
all three games are available now on
Steam and Xbox PC game pass thanks for
watching and enjoy the rest of day of
the devs
foreign
[Music]
our next game includes scenes and
experiences that while certainly every
day are not often portrayed in media
such as menstruation and the proper
hygienic care of your sex toys The
Game's creators triple topping profess a
desire to bring these types of untold
stories to the Forefront to express
their feminist ideals and just to make
the types of games they want to play
dead pets Unleashed follows a bassist
Gordy and her punk band dead pets as
they navigate a complicated World
Balance your well-being your finances
and your band success all while
exploring relationships and Performing
various tasks just to get through the
day with its unique visual style and
original soundtrack dead pets Unleashed
will have you vibing out until the very
last set
hi my name is aim cell and I'm the
marketing lead and co-writer at triple
topping games we're an indie Studio
based in Denmark with a love of strong
narratives mini-games and work-life
balance
we're currently working on our next game
dead pets Unleashed a feminist narrative
and management light game about punk
music friendship and growing up
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you'll shape the future of dead pets a
struggling demon punk band before they
decide to call it quits
foreign
[Music]
has big plans for the group but as the
members have turned 30 life has gotten
in the way
[Applause]
the gameplay is primarily conversations
between the characters
with a whole bunch of mini-games
throughout to break up the dialogue
these minigames can include anything
from working a shift at Gordy's Diner
and even a rhythm game for band practice
[Music]
[Applause]
you must also manage Gordy's well-being
the band's first taste of success comes
with the cost of Gordy's mental health
and physical well-being
Gordy struggles with what it means to be
a victim and how to move forward
multiple endings Gordy will have the
chance to grow up in different ways
depending on the choices you make
we're excited to announce that dead pets
Unleashed will be coming to consoles
Xbox PlayStation and switch when the
game releases next year
the demo is currently out on Steam and
itch.io and we've just launched an
additional episode of the game in the
demo so there's even more for you to
check out please wishlist the game on
Steam and be sure to follow us on
socials
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
so we've all heard of city building but
what about City unbuilding
in Terra nil the reversity Builder by
free lives you'll not only be tasked
with Reviving Barren Landscapes into
thriving ecosystems you'll then be
challenged to remove any trace of your
involvement leaving the beautiful
environs to the re-homed Bears and deer
and who doesn't want to save bears
restore a World's ecosystem with this
fresh take on a popular genre this is
Tara nil
hi I'm Jonathan how Yoon I work at an
indie game studio in Cape Town South
Africa called free lives I'm the artbead
on a game called Terry Mill
[Music]
welcome to Tara nil
a reverse City Builder where you are
tasked with restoring the wastelands
utilize windmills to power your
facilities cleansing the surrounding
soil
and preparing it for irrigation
once the grasses and waterways have been
rejuvenated it's time to move on to more
complicated ecosystems
mangroves
swamplands fields of flowers
rain forests
actions that may at first appear
destructive are in fact important
aspects of a larger ecosystem
with the restoration of symbiotic
habitat Comes The Return of biodiversity
your work completed it's time to pack
your things and be on your way
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
mobile Netflix games
next up from developer outer loop I'm
thrilled to bring you thirsty suitors
now this game defies description it's an
interesting combination of skateboarding
cooking dating and battling it's also
Scott pilgrimes filtered through the
lens of authentic Indian culture
hi I'm chandana kanayaka the Crave
director at outer loop games and I'm
here in Timber Hills Washington to talk
about thirsty suitors
[Music]
hey y'all you've been Reckless with
other people's hearts for so long Jala
it was a matter of time before you
wrecked your own morning Ma
wow Jala hi Auntie you pissed off your
exes so much they organized against you
[Music]
foreign
ERS is an action adventure RPG about
immigrant culture resolving
relationships family pressure and
expressing oneself the player gets the
shape jaw is fate while battling her
exes in turn-based combat
skating cooking and through narrative
choices
at the start of the game Jala returns to
her hometown of Timber Hills after
wrecking her relationships with her
family friends and her exes
[Music]
foreign
tries to repair her relationships with
her family and friends through cooking
[Music]
to blow off steam dolla go skating at
her old skate park while battling
skatepunks and their leader soundie the
bear
[Music]
foreign
meets up with her third grade
ex-boyfriend Sergio who is still thirsty
for her
[Music]
Shuffle
I can't believe you brought your mom
into this you started it
yeah
Sergio is one of six X's Jala will
confront through the course of thirst
suitors 10 chapters Dallas overbearing
grandmother has sent surprise suitors to
win her hand will she ultimately
reconcile her relationships who knows
our inspiration for this game is based
on our lived experiences and fantasies
of our diverse team while the game is at
Times personal we think the specificity
of the themes of family Dynamics love
and fighting with x's joyfully expressed
in bigger than life colorful ways will
resonate with wider audiences time to
cook
[Music]
that's acceptable
coming soon patience
one of the most important genres of game
to me is the adventure game and the
pioneers of that genre are Ken Roberta
Williams the founders of Sierra and
Roberta Williams the designer of King's
Quest and phantasmagoria they have a new
game they're showing here at day of the
devs a reimagining of not one of their
own games but of Colossal Cave That's
right The Original Adventure game the
Texas Adventure classic that started it
all is being reimagined by Canon Roberta
as a 3D experience with VR elements so
I'm very excited to check it out along
with you right now
hi I'm Ken Williams and and your name is
I'm Roberta Williams and we're known for
creating a company called Sierra online
they did some games that you might have
heard of like Half-Life Leisure Suit
Larry um a couple hundred titles
including about 20 by her what did you
do oh wow I did games like king's quest
phantasmagoria lower Laura Beau murder
mystery
among others
well and how did you get into the
business a leading question
well I got into the business by playing
a game uh called Colossal Cave back in
early 1980 was the first Adventure game
computer game even really developed and
uh I loved it and I wanted to do my own
game that was just like it and and I did
called Mystery House
well to make a long story short Sierra
did very well we grew it to a thousand
employees ran it for almost 20 years
why are we building again yeah what game
are we building your turn and what game
are we building uh we're building
Colossal Cave that's the original game
that I played early 1980 and that a text
Adventure game it was and now we're
bringing it back in full color full 3d
foreign
at the end of a road before a small
brick building
around you is a forest
a small stream flows out of the building
and down a gully even as many times I've
played it every time I hear that opening
line it it had sent shivers through you
I mean it's just such a cool line I like
the idea of the game because not many
games in this industry have lasted 50
years very few games can say that where
people are still playing
the door is closed
you see a small brick building
there's a shiny brass lamp nearby
you are crawling over cobbles in a low
Passage
Brass Lantern
The Brass Lantern is shining brightly at
your feet is a small pit breathing
traces of mist
the hole is filled with wisps of white
Mist swaying to and fro almost as if
alive
rough Stone steps go upward behind you
ended upwards scrambled to the South
leads to a chamber
it's perfect symmetry to take the game
that started Sierra and um
and do the same game for a whole new
audience for a new generation yes
foreign
it says you won't get it up the steps
you're in a low room veins of gold cover
the walls
happy to be back building a game we've
got a large team they've been working
very hard for a very long time and uh
yeah it's a wonderful game thank you
everybody goodbye
explore the vast darkness of the
mythical Colossal Cave and find the
valuable Treasures held Within
beware that many obstacles that stand in
your way and perilous encounters that
threaten to end your quest quickly
and without Mercy with many locations to
Traverse secrets defied and miles of
cabins to explore you'll never know just
put your own adventure inside Colossal
Cave will bring
[Music]
next up we have a world premiere from
Jasper and Jonas a fun fact is that they
met playing Animal Crossing during the
pandemic and decided to make this game
together
[Music]
and we're super excited to introduce the
world to our upcoming game sermount
[Music]
I sermon you're a little climber on a
huge Adventure you're on the journey to
become the first to climb the biggest
mountain in the world the mysterious
Mountain
[Music]
we wanted to make a game that conveys
the fun of climbing so we made a control
scheme that is fun and easy for
beginners but allow hardcore players to
do some pretty Sicky rules
[Music]
let's explore Mountain you will start to
notice that it's always changing shape
which means you will never find two
climbing routes that look exactly the
same
[Music]
in order to make it all the way to the
top you'll have to make use of all kinds
of items like ropes of course but also
more unconventional things like plungers
and teleporters
[Music]
you know what bring a friend if you're
climbing together then you'll always
have someone to catch you when you fall
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
and you're not gonna have to do it alone
you're going to meet many interesting
characters maybe while they are climbing
or maybe when you're just selling in at
one of the camps that you set up
[Music]
they will have all kinds of stories to
tell and maybe you will even uncover
some of the Mountain's many secrets
foreign
yeah basically it's been a lot of fun to
work on this game with Jonas
um I hope that it shows in the game
planning to release the game in 2023 you
can either wishlist it on Steam now or
visit the website to learn all about it
we can't wait to tell you more
thank you all for tuning in and we hope
to see you soon
[Music]
from our friends at devolver digital and
developers doinksoft this next game
Stars a Gruff bearded Woodsman hell-bent
on Revenge and armed with a unique gun
that doubles as an umbrella as you
investigate a series of cult-related
kidnappings you'll uncover a world
ravaged by corporate greed that soon
takes a turn towards the supernatural as
you blast your way through ghouls
gangsters cops and cultists alike this
is gunbrella or as we say where I'm from
gun brawling
below
I am Brit Brady
president
adoinksoff
we are a small Studio based out of
Oregon
currently working on the title gumbrella
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
umbrella
developed in Portugal this next title is
inspired by classic 1980s anime and set
among the neon graffitied streets of Neo
Hong Kong
it's an action adventure that follows
three different characters on three very
different missions which all intertwine
with one another as the mysteries of
this never-sleeping city reveal
themselves to you this is evolutis hi
everyone I'm Fernando Cruz the director
of evolutionary and I'm Jay Cruz the
lead artist and we are the founders of
book Life Studio
foreign
[Music]
driven game that combines vertical
opinion hand-draw animations
you can spot several references from 80s
90s in early 2000s animes and of course
American cartoons
the game has a dark and mature tone
so it is not appropriate for kids
whatsoever
oh
however violence can be prevented in
abilities it is up to you the player to
decide how you go about it
[Applause]
now let's talk about her main character
Chelsea Williams a well-renowned
wrestler struggling to deal with losses
in loneliness
foreign
she only has one friend she can trust
which is her cat Oliver
in the city of hengai where the game
takes place Nothing Is What It Seems
everything is an abstraction pandas are
corporate baskets copies of copies of
animals nobody has Everly actually seen
virtual vacations to holographic places
are used to sell illusions of Escape
only the player can decide where the
fantasy ends and the all her begins
right now I want to show you how the
stealth infiltration gameplay works
[Music]
[Applause]
depending on the outcome of the fight
whether you win or lose the story may
change which could cause an impact on
the city or even in Chelsea's life
so that's it for today thank you for
watching and do not forget to follow us
on our social media
with day of the dev celebrating 10 years
one thing that we've never actually done
in a showcase before is feature retro
games we tend to focus on pre-release
titles not stuff that's already been out
there for
you know a couple weeks a couple months
or let alone years or decades but we're
making an exception today because we
want to focus on developer digital
Eclipse with the Atari 50th Anniversary
Collection they didn't just dust off a
bunch of old games and slap them
together this is a marvelous collection
that goes an extra thousand miles to be
respectful to the source material but
also bring it into a modern age digital
eclipse is the best at this thing and if
you don't know who they are
you're gonna find out
hey everybody this is Mike Mike I'm
president of digital Eclipse our mission
here is to celebrate the history of
video games and to do that right this
year we're celebrating atari's 50th
anniversary
foreign
[Music]
you navigate through this timeline
seeing artifacts from atari's 50 years
of existence and along the way you're
introduced to the games that are
contextualized by these artifacts
we don't want to just release another
game collection we actually want to go
deeper than that so we include things
like interviews
design documents
historical flyers and ads all these
things we feel give context to
everything we do and especially give
context of 50 years of Atari
I feel the best Atari games ever made
have been made in the last five years
like I think I think the home routine is
incredible people figured out and it's
unfair to compare because the original
people had like five weeks to make
the only way you can really tell the
story of Atari over 50 years is to
gather and collect the stories from the
people who were part of Atari who were
Atari
it's fun to program for the 2016 because
it's Unique it's so limited that it it
it helps you edit you know and so you
can't you can't do everything you can't
imagine experience and then implement it
on the Atari you have to go the other
way around like what can I how many
blocks can I move on the screen like how
can I turn that into a fun game
I think for modern players especially
people are really young if they start to
play a game like Adventure it might come
across as something very simple and
crude but in reality the game is very
complex but for someone today they don't
really have that context so what we're
striving to do is to wrap that game with
the sort of context that puts you back
at that moment back at that period of
time when technology was still young and
hopefully in part what it felt like to
see that game for the first time we're
used to seeing Atari arcade games
releasing Atari 2600 games but we're
undergo a step further with this
collection we want to make sure we
included games from the Atari Links the
Atari Jaguar as well as the Atari home
computer line
foreign
aspects of the Atari 50th for us was to
revisit classic game designs games like
the early Vector games that Atari had
produced or haunted house for the Target
2600 or combat and tank what we set out
to do was to take these design pillars
from those games the Simplicity of those
games and reconstruct a modern
take on that
and by creating these reimagined
versions of these games our hope is that
we kind of act like a gateway drug of
sorts to bring modern Gamers into the
fold of what Atari is and help them
appreciate everywhere that Atari had
been
[Music]
in the game
what is happening everybody my name is
Justin Woodward one of the founders of
black voice and gaming a non-profit
organization based in Oakland California
designed to highlight black game
developers by giving them a voice to be
heard opening up Dev options with an
accelerator that provides accessible
opportunities that could lead to Success
Through a network in a Grassroots
community that represents the culture
with integrity and substance bvig
started out as an online showcase during
the 2020 civil unrest taking place
because of the excess of police
brutality that continues to occur the
initial showcase was created to be a
positive force during the time and the
amount of support from Partners in the
game Community was eye-opening we have
been collaborating with Publishers
fellow devs media outlets and
distribution platforms as well as others
to make this experience awesome the
accelerator has expanded past working
with devs and discoverability and we are
now working with developers on funding
options mentorship and introductions to
various platform forms such as
PlayStation valve Nintendo and Microsoft
as well as Publishers lawyers and
creators who can collaborate during
production
thanks to day of the devs we're going to
Showcase a couple of games that are a
part of the black voice and gaming
cohort that you will definitely enjoy
first we will be showing you the
beautiful and Charming action RPG slime
heroes from pancake Studios and then we
will slash into an arena style
competitive 3D fighting game Samurai
Zero from Neo interactive let's check
them out
slime Heroes is an action RPG where you
can play as an adorable slime to save
the world
foreign
[Music]
follows your slime who is discovering
the world that appears to be consumed by
a dark corruption Silva succumbed to the
corruption with all the other Guardians
you and I were among all that's left
crimes can defend themselves by forming
different melee weapons to fight against
this corruption including swords Spears
Hammers and much more
[Music]
each gooey weapon has its own moveset
for you to master
foreign
[Music]
each enemy drops different types of
skill gems that your slime can consume
and use you can also make new skills by
mixing and matching the different skill
gems together there are a wide variety
of skills to discover from Fireballs to
whirlwinds meteors and icebreath Demon
becoming a giant bowling ball
foreign
As You Adventure into the world you'll
come upon ancient ruins
many dungeons have some of the more
puzzly content slime here
it's a world to explore overgrown
jungles snowy tundres and molten hot
mountains
as you go deeper into the parts of the
world you'll discover the corrupted
ancient Guardians these are the toughest
most challenging boss battles in the
game
foreign
has unique skill patterns to learn how
to defeat once each boss is saved
they'll help you along in your journey
by giving you new weapons or some of the
most powerful skill gems in the game
each boss saved leads you closer to
unveiling the mysterious corruption
please wishlist slime Heroes on Steam
you can also keep up the latest news and
updates on Twitter and Discord
[Music]
foreign
hello everyone I'm ethos I'm one of the
founders of Neo interactive a Indie
Studio based in Detroit Michigan and
today I'm excited to share with you guys
our multiplayer PVP game Samurai zero
you play as a samurai a super-powered
being in our science fantasy Universe
called Edo
each of these Samurai have their own
attack strings and Combos and then when
on defense you can actually Dodge
deflect and break an enemy's resolve
with Precision mess
victory
eliminating enemies and completing
objectives grants you points and in
between these rounds you can spend those
points on unique talents that can
enhance your Samurai for the rest of the
match this allows players to customize
their own play style
we wanted to give players different ways
of playing whether it be an excellent
101 duel or t-based uv3 efforts like
elimination or an objective-based game
mode like control
[Music]
I can't believe that works
if any of this sounds interesting to you
well you can check out our game Samurai
zero currently right now available for
wishlist on Steam and look forward to
our next development update and play
test thanks so much for checking out our
game
yes make sure to check out the bvig
games we just shared on today's day of
the devs feature follow them on social
media and wish list of games on Steam or
wherever they could be found if you want
to check out more hot developers from
bvig please check the website
blackvoiceongames.org and follow us on
social media Twitter BVI gaming and
everywhere else at black voice and
gaming you can also support us through
donations which will go to developers in
the form of Grants and will help keep
the lights on for operations as well we
have showcases popping up this winter
and in the future and we'll be
collaborating on more events soon thank
you so much for tuning in happy day of
the devs everyone and much love to our
hosts double fine Productions and I am
8-bit you guys are awesome peace
we've got lots of world premieres in
this day of the devs and this one is a
nice surprise from developer strange
scaffold remember they're the dev behind
games that I'm going to attempt to
pronounce in the right order uh they got
long titles
an airport for aliens currently run by
dogs
I think I got left and space
warlord organ trading simulator I think
I nailed it this one's a really awesome
surprise enjoy
foreign
once upon a time a crew of adorable
animals robbed the largest bank on the
Eastern Seaboard and they thought they
got away with it but the problem is the
money inside that bank belonged to the
Mob and now you show up on their
doorstep 12 years later a private
investigator and they're telling you
their story in return for amnesty
they're also letting you decorate their
boat because however horrible your
fashion choices may be it's still better
than a bullet to the back of the head My
Name is Oliver Nelson Jr and I'm the
career director for the game that that
story belongs to Sunshine Shuffle
foreign
poker Adventure where hopefully you come
to care about the people you're playing
with more than the cards in your hand
just as they come and care about you
[Music]
if anyone out there has a kid who learns
to gamble because of this cute poker
game with the adorable animals in it
I just want to offer my apologies and
also say that's objectively funny and if
I can say this without being legally
liable
I hope it happens
[Music]
thank you
I'll be honest I've worked on a lot of
things and I've been up for nearly 24
hours now but I can't remember the last
time I was so excited
terrified to see how people would react
to a world I had played a part in
building I want to thank the day of the
devs people so much for giving us a
chance to showcase our weird and
wonderful game here I want to thank you
for giving it a shot
[Music]
Tim Burton once asked us to imagine just
for one moment what life might be like
for a man who had scissors for hands
sure you could cut your hair really well
but could he ever find love or be loved
in return could he ever truly be
accepted by Society
this next game is bound to spark
meaningful discourse in a similar light
as it asks you to Don a VR headset and
imagine just for one moment what life
might be like if you add baseball bats
for hands how would you drive a car how
would you cook an egg
from the creators of what the golf this
is what the bat
I'm Ali I make the sounds
I'm Lucas and I make the code
[Music]
foreign this game is about life
in the way that life and baseball is
very similar
it's the struggle
[Music]
and
nobody really knows when it dance
I guess someone knows how to play but
not a lot of people yeah
it's a it's a game that requires a lot
of skill to exist
you live your life as as Betty who's
born with the best instead of hands
[Music]
you make breakfast
you were
go downtown
[Music]
play with our cake machines
take care of your farm you go to space
and all the stuff that happens in a
regular life
there's one elephant and then there's
like another elephant
I think we were just existing
[Music]
we're all about sports but we don't
really know anything about sports
what the [__] shortstop and he's just
like obviously it's between base two and
three
[Music]
almost exclusively
you
yes absolutely
[Music]
very excited for you to learn about
baseball
[Music]
that's chaotic I mean like it's always
going to be chaotic right
oh
[Applause]
sabotage is one of my personal fave
developers the messenger was totally
[__] badass and with sea of stars
they're paying homage to Classics Nest
RPGs in a way that's totally unexpected
they're making narrative decisions and
creating pixel magic that is just
mind-blowing I cannot [__] wait for
this game hey everyone my name is Teddy
I'm creative director over at sabotage
studio in Quebec City Canada we're
delighted to receive an invite for Day
of the devs but unfortunately because of
production we couldn't afford to travel
at the moment we'll still be taking a
break to look at all the amazing games
being presented but for now we have to
focus on the final Milestones as we're
on the road to launching sea of stars in
[Music]
sea of stars is a turn-based RPG it
takes place in the same universe as our
first game the messenger it tells the
story of two children of the solstice
who combined their powers of the Moon
and the Sun to create Eclipse Magic
which is the one power that can face off
against the creations of an evil
Alchemist known as the flesh Manson
takes inspiration from many obvious
Classics with dungeon crawling and
simple puzzles and of course turn-based
combat everything that has to do with
touching the game we were really
shooting for something where you you
feel like it's a world you can touch so
hoisting up jumping down seamlessly
going in and out of water to swim but
also in combat playing on this timed
input mechanics where every single move
that you do from from a regular attack
to a special combo attack you have input
that you can time to make the outcome
better deal more damage for example and
so the main focus of the game is really
the story a story that keeps moving
forward and it's less about this grindy
hitting a wall
foreign
you can sail around hang out on your own
boat talk to the crew to get reminders
about what to do next and things like
that so while we're on the road to uh
launch the game in 2023 after four years
it seems almost impossible to be saying
but that's what we're headed towards
right now so we will be in touch as soon
as we have an official launch date to
announce in the meantime we hope you
enjoy day of the devs thank you for your
time
[Music]
these games and this collection of
creativity and developers I love
developers I love the game that I love
you watching it so thank you our 10th
anniversary celebration isn't done yet
please join us on Saturday November 5th
in San Francisco at the Midway for our
first live Showcase in over three years
it's completely and totally free
seriously just RSVP at the link below or
if you want all the fun of party
crashing and none of the consequences
just show up we'll have over 70 games on
the floor way more than we could fit in
just one digital showcase can't wait to
see you there it's gonna be a blast
thank you to our musical performers if
you want to check out their stuff it's
really cool go to the links on screen
thank you once again to the master
himself dose one he's been contributing
to these digital showcases for Day of
the devs since their Inception he's been
DJing at the Live Events forever so
please check out his cool stuff links on
screen we have to thank our sponsors
without our sponsors this digital
Showcase of the Live Events none of it
would be possible extra special thanks
to PlayStation and idea Xbox for being
here since the very beginning and
supporting day of the devs it's been 10
years you've made this possible but we
also have a whole bunch of other
sponsors that have come on board since
we started this thing we got skybound
games
Annapurna interactive aquapower games
Armor Games
Atari devolver digital little digital
Eclipse GDC humble games and Humble
Bundle
Kepler interactive Kailua Knight raw
Fury Razer Samsung steam and the valve
team
Studio mbhr
summer game Fest and Team 17 as this
thing has grown it's gotten way more
expensive and without these sponsors we
could not do any of this go to
davids.com to keep up to date on all our
digital shows and our Live Events the
future sign up for our newsletter and
find out what's happening on day of the
devs thanks for joining us
it's been a blast we'll see you next
time
thanks for watching and see you in San
Francisco November 5th maybe what games
are you going to be able to play at the
show don't worry we've got you covered
right here with this alphabetical
sizzling Supercut of every game playable
at the show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you